je suis allé voir sur votre compte
instagram ou là vous jouez vraiment un
double langage parce que sur le compte
instagram c'est le jeu du chat et de la
souris avec la police si vous n'êtes
plus dans un truc beaucoup plus festif
que ce que vous nous racontez là ce soir
donc c'est pourquoi pas c'est chacun
voilà mais là ce que vous nous dites en
gros on nous dit on n'est pas content
d'une décision de justice donc parce
qu'on n'est pas contents d'une décision
de justice seulement d'une justice à
aller faire des rondes et aux enfants de
6 à 12 mais je peux terminer juste et
après vous dites on a compris qu'on
avait fait peur donc maintenant on
arrête de faire ces rodéos sauvages dans
les rues si j'ai bien compris mais on va
aller continuer sur le périph si c'est
vraiment ça c'est pas du sujet en fait
le fond le fond de la pensée c'est
clairement un avant avant l'arrivée de
mme annie j'étais l'arrestation de
manier gt qui qui acquiert entraîné on
va dire le début de ces manifestations
c'est principalement le fait comme je
disais précédemment pas d'être un petit
peu stigmatisés parce qu'on appartient à
une zone géographique ou à une certaine
catégorie socioprofessionnelle par la
suite justement
on est on est à un système enfin pas
dire on est des gens différents avec
chacun a une façon différente de penser
certains cautionne un parle d'un bang on
sait qu'il a été fait d'autres non a le
le fond du truc c'était principalement
en fait de de dire aux médias vu que
vous nous voyez enfin aux médias au
maire alors lis je veux que vous voyez
comme tel ha ha ha ha ha d'une certaine
façon on vous renvoie cette image en
fait que vous voulez me coller et on
affiche en fait cette image justement de
dalton de récalcitrants et a en réponse
un petit peu rajouté mais pour ajouter
j'ai dit au coach et on était encore
plus hors la loi c'est un petit peu le
trait on dit que le fond du truc n'a
jamais été à un moment donné en fait de
porter atteinte à à à la personne
individuelle et c'est pour ça qu'on
s'excuse et on s'est rendu compte en
fait des problèmes quand jean dell et
rodrigues et parce que ça n'a jamais été
le but le but n'a jamais été
révisé mais c'est pour faire parler de
mode qui dérape et vous vous dites non
non pas du tout le rap
c'est quoi le mouvement c'est quoi la
revendication par la violence et la
défiance aux autorités sa part du rap en
fait sa part du joueur violence et après
ce mouvement le clip il est quand même
assez violent il ya quand même des armes
et tout ça reste je suis sûr
il faudrait pour que ça s'arrête on en
attendait 100 vera s'aventure sur leurs
revendications comme a dit amir ali
c'est juste que aujourd'hui quand vous
défier les gens j'aimerais bien voir
venir sera pas sur les rodéos pareil on
ne nous donnait à chaque fois qu'on part
sur un rodéo on annonça la police on
annonce sur un site de la seconde
annonce oui parce que jean pierre
marquois qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils
ont clairement dit nous allions il
interdisait les rodéos nous aimons
habitants de ces quartiers largeur non
sens je les entends que ça ça y'a pas de
soucis le but
non nous sommes tous heureux qu'ils
aient pas eu de drame sont tous heureux
que ce soit du gaz un passant qui sera
passée mais ces rodéos sont pratiqués
encore par des professionnels se faire
chasser par pendant une heure avec des
hélicos 50 voitures de police c'est pas
de la chance au bout d'une heure c'est
du talent avoir une certaine
condition
mag n ya pas de profession
qui constitue parce que là vous êtes
quatre mois moi je m'interroge parce que
pour l'exemple donné par
exemple nous avons envahi le terrain à
lyon lors d'un match de khl c'était des
mecs de votre collectif vous êtes
combien de prêt
de titres
plus ou moins d'accord on est pas on
n'est pas des marginaux quand vous dites
quand vous entendez ce comité se trouve
quelqu'un peut-il expliquer aux au maire
europe écologie de lyon ce qu'il peut
faire avec les dalton lyon devient le
far west avec ces gens qui font la loi
maintenant ils escaladent la prison il
envoie un colis à l'intérieur bientôt
ils vont la dynamite et qu'est ce qu'il
préfère c'est nous recevoir le maire il
nous
le but mer ils nous regardent et qu'ils
avaient une vraie revendication
peut-être qu'il va vous recevoir le but
en fait c'est d'ouvrir le débat avec la
mairie la préfecture sur toute cette
répression qui a appliqué dans les
quartiers dont surtout dans notre
quartier dans le 8e arrondissement
c'est lassant c'est lassant et cette
histoire avec manny gt ça a juste été la
goutte d'eau ces terres incarcéré pour
un pour complicité de rodéo et ça passe
pas ça peut pas passer cc66 sanvensa
avec le maire de justice mais non la
justice et un le préfet a énormément
d'impact sur la décision de justice on
sait qu'une bouteille iffim qu'ils ont
des relations qui se croisent dans des
restos qui mangent ensemble ça tout ça
on le sait on n'est pas né d'année
rappelé non plus gilles verdez moi je
vous comprends pas il ya la contestation
par le rap ça c'est sain dans une
société mais là vous avez dérapé excusez
moi vous avez vrille et le rodéo urbain
le rodéo urbain s'est mise en danger de
la vie d'autrui c'est à dire que dans le
8e arrondissement les gens ils ont peur
de sortir ils ont peur de ce type en
moins d'enfants donc c'est terrifiant
du tueur non mais vous ne pouvez pas
contester une décision de justice on a
compté 10 mais si vous la contester tout
le monde reste en belgique
demain ce qu'on donne on s'est parlé
on s'est dit courant quand c'est la peur
du temps qu'est ce qui se passe quand
conteste une décision de l'uci dans une
cité qu'est ce qui se passe généralement
brûle tout c'est contre-productif j'ai
pas envie de brûler la voiture mon
voisin du cinéma c'est pas bon qu'est ce
qu'on voulait montrer ce qu'on voulait
c'est le fils aîné simon final c'est de
me le faire aux façons de le faire
aujourd'hui le but c'est quoi on
aimerait bien ouvrir le débat je veux
ouvrir le débat avec le maire quand on
qu'on puisse asseoir conquis s'asseoir
été volée
contrée que cette traite donc vote votre
principal problème c'est que vous
trouvez qu'il ya trop de répression dans
le quartier du même armement de la
pression des
conseillers donc c'est ça le truc que
l'on demande c'est au préfet et au maire
justement ne pas en faire une affaire
personnelle et vous voulez quoi voulez
qu'il discute avec les jeunes de 300
voix disent qu ils ont jamais discuté
avec nous pour trouver quoi pour trouver
des solutions pour que ses solutions
ambition pour apporter des choses
nouvelles en fait la solution si la
solution c'est
autoriser les rodéos sauvages
c'est quoi la solution c'est vous
l'avions dit discuter pour trouver quoi
pimenter les gens que moi qui a dit une
fois
ci avait plus de bibliothèques que deux
que deux terrains de foot dans les cités
il y aurait plein de einstein dans les
cités le fait est que l'actuel
actuellement on est on est uniquement
stigmatiser est perçu comme sims à huy
effectivement autant distrait pour pour
manifester un petit peu notre
mécontentement et dire vous voulez qu'on
soit comme ça on peut l'être et sans
forcément y'a de leur porter atteinte en
fait encore une fois je le répète à
l'individu oui mais en vous présentant
comme une sorte de bande organisée comme
ça c'est des méthodes qui ne représente
pas c'est pas c'est pas une façon de
dire j'ai envie de dialoguer c'est au
contraire
mais non il a proposé de dialoguer avec
elle vous
savez pas où est autorisée tous nous a
permis justement de pouvoir dialoguer un
mec comme ça au moins on peut avancer
sur cet hiver à ce que nous attendons
aussi aux habitants je pense à vous me
dites moi j'essaie toujours d'arranger
il faut savoir qu'on est humain qu'on a
des frères quand on a des soeurs qu'on
adore vraiment qu'on a dépassé on a des
fous d'identité qu'il accordait aux gens
qui disent vous êtes juste dire à cactus
que j'ai entendu mon dieu tu vas
recevoir ces racailles c'était un coup
tu es tu le sais mais vous un peu fâché
pas fait le job et je déteste le mot
racaille est-ce que vous tenez on est
exactement comme vous
que j'ai envie de vous demander si donc
aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que qui serait que vous
arrêteriez voilà de semer un petit peu
la panique dans le 8e arrondissement
c'est vrai qu'à lyon j'étais qu'il ya
plein de gens qui sont un peu stressés
et je pense que ce soir de vous voir ça
va peut-être plaisir de les tensions
donc c'est plutôt c'est une bonne et
gérer les temps changent et vous précis
au pays au peuple et non mais s'apprête
à péter détention ce soir aussi de chivu
qui vous ai vu ce soir et mais juste on
a tous envie de savoir qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire et que doivent faire les les
autorités pour que ça avance donc c'est
quoi voulez allez y au maire pourquoi
pour que pour qu'ils puissent parler
avec les jeunes du viiie arrondissement
atteint exactement mais est ce que mon
adresse commander coin juste je dis
juste un vrai est ce que vous imaginez
bien qu'il ya des problèmes dans toutes
les haines et dans toutes les villes
bien sûr et c'est donc plein de quartier
comme l'imaginé si tous les jeunes
faisait ça et se met un petit peu j'ai
envie de dire la panique dans leurs
quartiers dans leur arrondissement
serait facilitée en général alors
arrondissement ils se font pas chier non
plus ils sont pas embêtés à chaque fois
par la police et par l'uefa après ça
dépend celui ci en a beaucoup qui en a
beaucoup qui sont dans ce cas
d'après vous que pour être entendu un
collectif
était pas déroger
une chose à dire je disais depuis
toujours c'est pas nous qui avons
inventé les rodéos mais aux dernières
elles sont pratiquées partout et depuis
tout temps dans tous les arrondissements
de lyon le problème c'est qu'une fois
que ça arrive dans les quartiers tels
que le bellecour dans les quartiers un
peu centre-ville un peu rainbow et bat
partir de la cia tout le monde qui est
soudainement choqué et c'est ça que j'ai
du mal à comprendre c'est pas deux motos
qui passe à 14 heures en plein après
midi qui ont fait quelques nuisances
parce qu'il faut savoir que la première
des choses la première raison qui a
choqué les gens justement qui était à
bellecour parce que matin il parle de la
peur aux des passants mais la première
chose qui les a choqués faut savoir que
c'est le bruit donc moi je pense qu'une
harley davidson se tend de 8 ans crosse
alors j'ai donc c'est le bruit c'est une
question nuisances les daltons choisi
juste un truc je vous dis tout ce que je
pense oui je pense que si demain le
maire ou les autorités vous reçoivent
qu'est ce que ça va faire ça va donner
des idées aux autres il faudra vous avez
vu et dalton ils ont fait 6 1 fait ça
ils ont été rose ou est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui on s'est peut-être mieux
de calmer un petit peu les choses et
essayer de repartir est-ce que vous
allez continuer les rodéos pas alors
juste pour répondre en partie à ce que
vous êtes en train de rebondir sur 100 m
dos d'un côté on dit alors c'est rachida
dati est
là bas
si vous pensez que c'est pas un bon
moyen de s'exprimer
je vous ferai remarquer qu'on est là
ouais ouais ouais mais collectif en
question mais c'est sa méthode c'est moi
d'accord vous de votre côté on vous
demande pas de je comprends que vous ne
comprenez pas on n'est pas forcément
vous avez eu besoin de venir ici pour
qu'on comprenne votre message a enfin
négocieront le comprenez pas l'anglais
très bien expliqué fallu non c'est
dommage j'aurais ce que ce
mouvement parce que moi
même les faire passer pour des guignols
en parlant des policiers et moi quand
j'entends ce genre de phrases minima
mobile ou de mauvaises mains partout
dans les épandeuses je me dis ils
veulent quoi il veut le faire ils
veulent creuser le propose et qui c'est
qui
qui existe entre la population et les
autorités publiques sans merci avec la
peinture qui sont dit ça aussi je n'en
mets là messieurs